you're right there's a lot of ish like i
know a lot of people that don't want
kids because of the way our world has
been going yeah so i think that may have
why is it like that the world's going
like we have a lower rate of poverty
than we ever have had in the entirety of
human history really
we're not getting paid as much as we
should no because the way the inflation
has gone up oh inflation's bad yeah
we're not getting paid more so it's like
like right you're right you're
outrageous
my parents my parents right able to buy
a house right right out of college
that is impossible like in our day and
age it's impossible it's just not gonna
happen we could barely pay rent like
with just a regular job like with no
experience coming out of college like
you know it's just not there's a
a lot of
things in the way that weren't in the
way tend to so you're saying you're
saying like a lot of people well but the
other problem is like consumer debt and
like that's like 80 of consumer debt is
owned by women so like women aren't like
good at saving
so it's like partially like our own
fault if we're in a problem where you
have 80 like 80 like because the other
genders aren't doing it i think are more
concentrated on like when it comes to
money management so i don't think it
depends on family as well so also like
just recently started having our own
banking yes isn't it that a woman
couldn't open a bank account until like
shortly after
uh voting was
yeah but yeah but
what does that have to do with us today
like
nothing
no no no no i'm sorry no no this is that
had nothing to do with me something that
happened in the 20s i felt like i'm like
a bank
that was only 30 30s for even let's say
50s 60s i wasn't alive you can't you
can't believe you're spending you can
know you cannot blame your spending
habits
let me finish talking i let you talk a
lot jessica
baby
listen at the end of the day being a
woman of color
when it comes to money and all that
we're a lot more careful about this kind
of stuff because it was 19. you know our
history does not prove well when it
comes to finances and education you know
and we're trying to work better well
it's something that should be taught in
schools like financial literacy
investing and luckily in my high school
yeah we needed at least two years of
financial literacy classes yes so
but you know when you have half of the
country not even being able to read at a
sixth grade level
it's going to get kind of hard for us to
have
uh understanding of both reading and
money like
i think that
one reason why that statistic that you
shared is so low amongst women
is um
you like sparked something it's because
that
we
it's shared
more like financial literacy and correct
me if i'm wrong it's shared more with
people who are wealthy wealthy yeah
already wealthy and that typically comes
from the caucasian community and it's
something that isn't well i'm talking
about like women only in conclusion yeah
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying like
okay
you have to bring up that intersection
what i'm saying like even if it's like
the wealthy people have that knowledge
like they
um like it's half women like
yeah but i'm saying just like the
dynamic of whatever community you come
from i don't know
yeah
yeah they come from this community that
community but it's
very um
it's not talked about yeah it's not
talked about it as much and i can
understand why that would be
low because of just the dynamics from do
you feel like the the internet though is
kind of the great equalizer because you
have access to all this information that
like like you can you can look up like a
billionaire giving someone financial
advice yeah i do think that
you can access anything and everything
on the internet but if it's not
something that you grew up with you've
been taught like this is important like
financial literacy you need to
understand it you're not going to look
it up on your own i just from what i've
seen i don't think it's like a community
thing like i think women just spend
money on like clothes and like like like
more like looks yeah like like i think
women just have worse spending habits
than yeah and i do think that and i
think it's been
made possibly
as well yeah like men that we're the
ones who are going to consume this kind
of stuff like how often do you see
forever 21 talking about the men's
section yeah
that's what i'm saying
our whole media is like marketed towards
women everything you see is like for a
female audiences into a corner except
for this show keep up winning
always wanting to
tell me something yeah
yeah it becomes an issue in society can
i say something yeah go ahead i
disagree with that to an extent
let's not get damn she just shooting me
left there right
you're on my left right now
she said left and right so
i'm playing
hold on um i think i disagree with that
to an extent i can't like personally i'm
not remembering that i care about how i
look but i think this was my passion for
fashion right mm-hmm they're funny but
that's a personal thing
but i think in terms there's a lot of
guys males that are very invested in how
they look a lot more than women whereas
women can strong statistically you're
wrong
you're thinking of exceptions about the
role
yeah men will make a big purchase
culture and preference mm-hmm as well
like what you want as a person as well
yeah like for example like you can just
want to dress because you want to dress
up there's a there's an artist like
she's not in the fashion business she's
actually an artist
but she's just plays about in fashion
yeah i know but like like again remember
when we're having these conversations
we're talking about in general we're not
talking about like you want because why
does your your mind go to a specific
it's like you want to argue because
you're like oh this one person is an
exception to the stereotype because but
a stereotype but stereotypes
[Music]
is fully rooted in women yeah yeah like
accessories right
exactly
because they know we're gonna spend that
was the only thing that we could do at
some point also and also i think that
the society
i think that the main thing is like
women
i don't know the statistic of how many
women are in the world how many men but
typically sex cell and women are
sexualized and so that's why they geared
towards like they know they're going to
buy the stuff they know if they have if
they see a woman wearing something that
they look good and this the women are
going to be like
but are they sexualized for men or for
women if women make 80 percent of
consumer purposes
i think
historically like let's look like
historically like
when
like when women wore corsets and they
were right little right things that you
think that like
layers
that was because they were being brought
out into society to find a husband and
they were being sexualized so i feel
like that's also a point to be made like
they like when they had money it's like
oh well let's spend this on a dress but
again kathy but what is that like what
does that have to do with us today
because it's morphed into where it
trickles down to where we are but i just
i just i just i just believe in personal
responsibility like if you have bad
credit and you were born in 2020 like
that's your own fault